So the terms genius and intellectual disability are really not fair because IQ
is not the same thing as creativity. In fact, you can have disability,
cognitive or intellectual disability and yet have extreme talents and this is
best seen in savants. Savants are people who do in fact have Disability and yet
extreme and uncanny talents. Kim Peek is one of the better known examples of,
of a savant. Kim Peek for instance, could read a page in eight to ten seconds
that takes us three or four minutes to read. And he could remember 98% of it.
Up to years and years later, exactly what was on that page. He also could tell
you precisely what day of the week you were born on, if you give your birthday.
He could also tell you what your zip code was if you give him your address. And
yet, he couldn't dress himself, and nor could he understand metaphor. So, for
instance, the phrase get a hold of yourself, didn't really make sense to him.
So do you think that Kim Peek's IQ is a valid indicator of how smart he is?